hello and welcome to Week in Review with
me Jane secor kept mcgladrey piercing as
you look back at the biggest story of
the last seven days would have been your
top stories has to be two women on the
short list to be our next prime minister
Labour Party eat your heart out I sure
got report and absolutely damning on
Tony Blair under rock did well more on
both of those stories in a second but
first let's get a taste of what the week
was all about gunmen opened fire on
police officers during a protest in
dallas texas the most officers killed in
one incident since nine eleven the
shootings happened amid unrest over
recent police shootings of black men
following a second ballot Theresa May
and Andrea Letson will go head to head
to leave the Conservative Party and the
country while it was farewell Farage as
when you give leader announced he wants
his life back an intervention and went
badly wrong sir john chilcot delivered
his verdict on iraq war the former Prime
Minister Tony Blair attacked by families
of the dead and there was one terrorist
in this world that the world needs to be
aware
and his name's Tony Blair oscar
pistorius was given a six-year sentence
for killing his girlfriend reeva
Steenkamp fellow sportsman flannel messy
was handed 21 months in spanish calls
for tax evasion while the FBI said
Hillary Clinton should not face charges
over her use of private emails as
Secretary of State NASA scientists
celebrated as their Juno spacecraft
reached Jupiter any meaning for
emotional baggage in the finals of the
annual wife carrier competition in
Finland and a Viking thunderclap from
Iceland fans as their football team
returned home after reaching the
quarter-finals in bureau 2016
I'm going to be talking about whales and
a short while but at but the big news in
the last a few hours as we record this
is is that the dreadful shootings in
Dallas and the stun reaction of America
tour what's happened there no absolutely
you've got police killing black men and
now you have snipers killing police and
it's all part of a very divided America
that that also is heavily on there are
too many guns and there's too many
divisions and you've got to take the
guns away and you've got to heal the
divisions so the police aren't killing
black men to terms down with with the
first black president would you have
expected race relations to be better
than they are now in America much better
and I think it's a stain on his
presidency and I know people say he
there's a logjam he can't get gun reform
through but he the sense that he has
tried yet best i think he has been every
day what remains his presidency talking
about gun control hillary clinton has to
do the same i didn't get any chance with
Donald Trump because it's shameful that
last year 13,000 was at 14,000 people
were killed by guns in America is
insanity right let's move to politics
here and let's talk about bloody
difficult women Theresa May or Andrea
Ledson will soon be the new conservative
leader and prime minister and despite
the new blood on the way in the old
guard have called the contest a fiasco
well here's former Chancellor Ken Clarke
and a candid on microphone moment
talking about his candidates I don't
think the membership will vote for go
anywhere I remember being a suggestion
once about something we should do in
somewhere like Syria or Iraq and he was
so wild that I mimics changing looks
with Liam Fox it's quite a much more
right-wing to me but we we wish a
diffusing and Liam was raising eyebrows
I mean I think with Michael as Prime
Minister we go to war with these three
countries at once he did us all a favor
by getting rid of Boris who'd idea of
boys as Prime Minister's really connect
sort of happen I don't think either
Andrea legend or Boris Johnson actually
in favor of leaving the European Union I
don't know very well she said some are
couple years 83 years ago she's had a
poor line conversion and she does have
experience in the city and the Bank of
England and she's not one of the minus
tiny band of lunatics
think we can have a sort of glorious
economic future outside the single
market so long she understands that
she's not to deliver on some of the
extremely stupid thing she's been saying
factories yeah I miss Theresa I agree
with what you said let me treat this
bloody difficult woman will you and I
work for Margaret Thatcher it just gets
better every time I watch it I don't and
of course the hashtag bloody difficult
woman was trending as a lot of that
people who wanted made in 28 those
remarks go to 30 in fact she she's
rather pleased and she were using it in
the campaign because the large stamina
bloodson though it was damning of leptin
and but mrs. Thatcher was a difficult
woman but she was a stunningly
successful Prime Minister the longest
serving primaries of the 20th century
and inet to resume won't make the
mistake have tried to be the next mrs.
Thatcher she's got to be treason made
but there she is a very strong woman
she's an authoritative and serious and I
think she's going to win authoritarian
as well as authoritative she is she is
the harder candidate for labor to deal
with they much prefer LEDs are not least
because of a dodgy cv wanting to bring
back fox hunting her sort of 19th
century views on on gay people the fact
she wanted to remove the minimum wage in
employment rights maternity rights from
some workers so should be a much easier
target but Labour Party in a position of
criticizing this is going to be a second
female friends again by the conservative
party why while the Labour Party yep
bringing forward candidates but Jay
you're quite right it's a shameful when
Labour presents itself as a party of
equality and opportunity that in 116
years it's never had a woman leader and
every time it's asked the question has
always been found a man perhaps the next
leader will be whether it's Angela regal
or somebody well but also these two
women have got there without any
artificial ater then there's been no
positive discrimination they've got
their own merit and ability they were
chosen because the Tory members taurine
MP think they're the best for the job
label tried all these measures with all
women shortlist and they're still
nowhere near I mean Anton regal says she
might run against Jeremy yeah but you
know later Labour's Labour's got most of
the women MPs in the House of Commons
but it's shameful at somebody like
Barbara castle
me in the past or Margaret Beckett or
Harriet Harman the last to work
caretaker leaders but they were never
fully thank you beautiful leader yeah
well I think it could've been a very
good leader in 2010 well let's move on
to labor because we've been talking
about them and has momentum gone for
Corbin to go the Labour Party's still in
turmoil about whether Jeremy Corbyn can
or still remain leader I should have a
listen I have a huge responsibility I'm
carrying out that responsibility and I'm
carrying on with that responsibility I
want to reach out to all our members to
all our supporters to all our trade
union affiliates and to my colleagues in
Parliament come together now for that
work well it didn't look like a hostage
video you just said you're kind of
expected to be holding a newspaper with
the date to prove when it was recorded
but now I mean he is elected if they if
the MPs and they launched their coup if
they want to replace him they will have
to have a formal ballot and beat him
politically but the odds are now I think
that the members would elect him again
because they don't feel he's been given
long enough to succeed or fail in his
own terms and Owen Smith and Angela
Eagle who be both been pushed forward as
potential challenges can't decide
themselves I think so oh shut up yeah
they do because this I mean we've had
the Emma Skye been filming and your
eagle it was the shadow business sector
II coming out of the house every morning
sir Jeremy doesn't Susan I'm gonna run
I'm good well when is she gonna run
through the slowest runner in the world
you something taller than the hair
though it's not was the fastest isn't
this is a farce everybody knows Jeremy
Corbyn is useless except Jeremy Corbyn
he's lost eighty percent support of the
parliamentary party and now we read that
the Labour Party in the country has
increased by 150 to 200 thousand since
the referendum which would be more of
these headbanger lefties join you hate
ya a democracy don't you Norman and jump
I hate democracy like him I'll join you
and Tony you know democracy doesn't work
if the leader of a party loses the
support his parmigiano I thought it
doesn't work I find it very hard to see
labour winning a general election with
jeremy corbyn I've given him a temp
percent chance maybe maybe that is
generous but because he's elected
you gotta unelected him you have to beat
him you can't just I understand the
frustration of all those MPs who have to
deal with him and they know he's
officers chaotic and he can't
communicate well with the country he
can't get his message across and while
you might excite a small portion of the
country can you get a big enough broad
enough alliance all those questions
there but you have to beat him in an
election he was critical was inhibit
only Blair this week Chilcott report was
out at seven years and 2.6 million words
inside it sir john chilcot released his
findings into the iraq war heavy
criticism from him for the former Prime
Minister Tony Blair it was revealed that
he told the u.s. he would stand with
them whatever months before the war
disguise political editor feisal Islam
has this report 13 years after the
invasion of Iraq a seven-year inquiry
and so much of it a verdict on one man
Tony Blair and for his anti-war
detractors there was much in sir john
chilcot 2.6 million words to agree with
we have concluded that the UK chose to
join the invasion of Iraq before the
peaceful options for disarmament had
been exhausted and Sir John unearthed a
memo that seemed to show the former PM
committing to President Bush eight
months before war on July the 28th Mr
Blair wrote to President Bush with an
assurance that he would be with him
whatever as the families accorded it was
no whitewash but Mr Blair was not
accused of lying not acting illegally an
emotional xpm mostly defiant but
starting is a very specific apology the
intelligence assessments made at the
time of going to war turned out to be
wrong the aftermath turned out to be
more hostile protracted and bloody than
ever we imagined for all of this I
express more
sorrow regret and apology that you may
ever know or can believe mr. Blair's
views were not convincing those families
of British military veterans I've gone
back to that time when I learn that my
brother had been killed and there was
one terrorist in this world that the
world needs to be aware of and his name
is Tony Blair the world's worst
terrorist the heart of it all a man
ready to apologize for mistakes of
planning and process but adamant that
all those years ago he made the only
decision a prime minister could well the
chilcot report showed that he hadn't
lied that that the intelligence may have
misled him but that he didn't lie but he
exaggerated guy and he gave those
private commitments the bush in those
love letters which were the most
fascinating bit of the inquiry including
that you know I'll be with you whatever
I think some people will still believe
he did lie they they interpreted
differently to chill cotton Blair him
himself and this is an indelible stain
on Tony Blair knees premiership he will
never be able to cleanse overshadows
will disagree on this but look the
Labour did a lot of good things knows 13
yrs reviving the NHS minimum wage
employment rights piece of normal but
this is what he'll be remembered it also
showed as well shamefully that he hadn't
done enough he had not exhausted the
options where they could have had a
peaceful out solution here he didn't use
the United nature he was hell-bent on
going to all that was the truth but the
other thing which i think is so awful
for the families we suspected it but
Chilcott is clear he sent men and women
into combat with ill-prepared equipment
inadequate equipment and that is
unforgivable for the 179 who died and
the many more who have lost limbs and
suffered injuries that's their point is
there Kevin because that's different
from making a wrong political decision
if you are sending you know your men and
women in there without the protection
they need no absolutely it's almost
always the case though an Army's ready
to fight a war at the end of the war on
that the starter of the war but military
commanders to have questions to to
answer over that because yes if you're
going to send somebody to warn I'm going
to put them in danger they should have
the very best
and that's available and they didn't
okay right time for our quiz now can you
tell me why the people of kidlington
okay oh oh they do know all of us yeah
I'd you know find out after the break
welcome back to we can review with me
Jane second I'm job by Kevin McGuire
associate editor of The Daily Mirror and
Andrew Pierce consultant editor of The
Daily Mail that before the break we
asked why the quiet oxfordshire village
of kidlington has been in the news at
you both know don't you it's been a
stampede of Chinese tourists there and
locals have been used why they're there
cuz course they don't speak English well
we've sent Lisa doubt see if she could
find out an ordinary street in an
Oxfordshire village teeming with
tourists from China taking selfies
posing in gateways and perhaps a look
around a garden or two Martha and mum
Annie are in the garden over there I
can't understand the attraction i would
say that we regularly see them three
times to four times a week we saw the
mall in like the street since going into
people's front gardens and sitting on
their benches i know i'm famous and
everything but locals in Kidlington
filmed the visitors filming them they
even turn up at the vicarage they
stopped and they began to take photos
and they began to pose you know at the
garage a more bog-standard draw our
toilet there's been ladies queuing up to
use this toilet which I'm quite
surprised that yes why this unassuming
village was picked we might never know
their pictures though must make
interesting viewing back at home and it
doesn't what what that doesn't answer is
why nobody really that one seriously
think it's where the dirty family lived
in in Harry Potter sort of course that
wasn't different nations like to share
its being in Midsomer Murders or
something like that play what I don't
it's honor it's vista village from those
i think it might be a stop off point
yeah but i'm all that it's just that
actually
1970s bungalows or something they don't
really see and they think they're
fascinating no you should go but why
don't go Stonehenge or dom cathedral or
my favorite like line is that apparently
want one tourist ask somebody figured if
they could have a go at mowing the lawn
actually the resident refuse oh yeah oh
they can come round awesome actually
yeah right well let's move away from
their kidding to the back to politics
and we've said goodbye to one person
this week you said it was never a career
politician and that with all his
political ambitions fulfilled it was
time to go we are talking of course
about nigel farage who announced he was
stepping down as leader of you Kip but
he hasn't yet given up a salary is an EU
MEP I came into politics from business
because I believed that this nation
should be self-governing I have never
been and I've never wanted to be a
career politician my aim in being in
politics was to get Britain out of the
european union that is what we voted for
in that referendum the two weeks ago and
that is why i now feel that i've done my
bit that I couldn't possibly achieve
more than we managed to get in that
referendum and so if it it's right that
I should now stand aside as leader of
you kept during the referendum campaign
I said I want my country back and what
I'm saying today is I want my life back
and it begins right now thank you sort
of him when abouts journalist three
quite live my life like back this summer
we're not going to get a chance to that
but I think he's right to go he's a tube
mission mission accomplished and he'll
stay on as an MEP for two years and so
he can keep the government's feet to the
fire make sure that they don't road back
on any of the deals to get out of the EU
and he said he's had a great run come on
he's incredibly successful as a
politician who couldn't get elected to
Parliament and field seven times but it
he's gonna spend more time down to Bob I
imagine he's got exactly had he ever won
a he made it very clear he's a cheap I
would I would like my country back I
would like back the gentler a kinder
more tolerant country we've left in part
baths and he's legging it now so he
doesn't have to pick up the pieces when
brexit goes badly
wrong because there is no plan as we're
seeing as people will pay 200 quid more
holidays this year because yeah drop in
the pound you should refundable it's at
a point though that Biogen and Boris
Johnson should have stayed on to just
sort out the mess but to follow through
Suraj's / arches in mep they've got no
clout no power that's one of the reasons
we should get out of this ridiculous
European Union cuz they've got any power
or authority and he's got no cloud with
no he's got no clout with the government
either and Boris Johnson well I technik
he'd have been brilliant on the
negotiations really even if he'd become
truly dedicated that yes but he is
hanging on to his 74 grande o and 40
grand expensive and I think we talked we
spoke to the actor Christopher waltz
this week on Sky News this is his
reaction to Nigel Farage going of course
the head rat would leave the sinking
ship it's inevitable you know they they
try to dress it up as heroic exit no
it's conceding defeat ask you something
Jane oh dear do not a fan anyway right
let's move on to your newspaper choices
and Kevin we've already seen Iceland's
Thunder cap and clapping all week in a
minute at but whales have also done
fantastically well have no they they
left in the semis but who'd have thought
they'd have got that far no not them
actually first tournament since 1950 it
was brilliant for Wales but actually was
brilliant for the rest of Britain and
I'm an england fan we went out abysmally
but chris coleman gareth bale and the
rest of them it was great to watch and
their fans were there singing and the
good behavior and just enjoying it no
and you know they deserve their victory
parade in angry and if I think it's like
a fairy tale wasn't it because everybody
thought they'd be out first and course
they go much further ninglin and their
great sportsman I think I loved on
Twitter everybody discovering well root
ancestry or you know I had a friend who
went well yeah that's all I've
everything I have for dinner Cardiff so
I could fit I felt I felt there and
their joy call it rather boast of links
were you does it haha Andrew to you now
the suburbs they're not as thriving as
they once were at the good life is
apparently no more
why well this is a report by a
think-tank the smith institute and they
say that the urban decay weeks we saw in
the inner cities is now transferring to
the suburbs where poverty is written
from twenty to twenty four percent and
this written saying unless there's
urgent action taken the suburbs where
all mcguire lives of course the burbs
will go the same way as inner cities i
think this is a slightly exaggerated to
me this report below I don't know
because I've never lived in the books i
AMA suburb I'm a suburban man and I live
in a nice leafy year if you londoner do
but i but i remember as a kid living on
a council estate in South Shields on
Tyneside and we won the edge there knows
poverty there was poverty in deprivation
that not as bad as there is now one of
the reasons got worse now is is because
of the decline in in employment and
decent job and it is not also about
young people that actually young people
coming for example to London just can't
afford to live in the city anymore so
now the suburbs are filling up with the
with people who don't have much money
who used to live in the center now
commuting in from this yeah I think that
is the big factor property prices in
sitting in the major city center but all
the money's gone into those city centres
and people might like to live in an old
warehouse and it's all gentrified and
that's great but gotta remember where
everybody else is an audience left
behind were a lot of people are left
behind yeah Kevin out onto term time
holidays now is proving quite a
money-spinner quite lucrative for a lot
of council it is ninety thousand people
have now been fined in the last academic
year sixty pounds it goes up hundred and
twenty if you don't pay within 21 days
and I think the change made in 2013 when
actually Michael Gove was education
secretary taken away discretion from
heads so you can only now have time out
if it's exceptional is a huge mistake a
huge user mistake and you effectively
punishing 90,000 people who are probably
otherwise completely law by aliens yes
and just to say the reason they put
these parents to take their children at
school sometimes it's because of their
at their own work commitment but also
the holidays are so much rice isn't it
for a lot of people a 60-pound fine from
school is like these holiday companies
are fleecing families they are well
they're they're using your supply and
demand that free market use or love and
worship thanks very much to the papers
at what about your ups and downs Andrew
was starting with you this week
you're listening us could this be man's
new best friend according to science at
queen mary university say they do
they've done a lot of research and goats
can be just as loyal and devoted to the
master as dogs all the mistress oh yeah
other than sheep apparently kept in
cheek yeah well I think sheep are quite
stupid because of the herd mentality but
I do think it's go to eat everything
don't let you know whenever you going to
visit goats and a petting zoo they're
always it in your pockets yeah I mean I
bought sweets oh well my first visit to
London so I got knocked over by a good
goat did you show Andrews best friend
shame it wasn't an elephant right so
ascending goats up but you're sending
down this week Chris Evans well it's all
over he's not he's gone from Top Gear
resigned before he was pushed he's also
lost his channel four sho tier five
friday so a very bad week for chris
seven the feeling figures were simply
not good enough that the viewers just
didn't take to him what's wrong it was a
car crash for him and it just didn't
work yeah but isn't very popular on the
radio and t if i was very popular when
it was all it's just it's it's the fit
isn't it and where the right fit it has
no chemistry with his co-presenter and
BBC say they're not going to replace him
okay so we're sending him down Kevin you
are sending up now this is an
interesting what it's a robot rectum yes
a an imperial college london of how to
build their own rectum I they're going
to call it the Andrew because he talks
out of his nevertheless they've had to
invent it because there's only one
person registered to have a finger
inserted in their human want to test
site yeah it's a rectal teaching
assistant say there's only one in the UK
one registered obviously worried what
happens if he decides just want to do it
anymore he must have a very sore bottom
the cloudy what I'm carry this little
versatile it is very serious because
it's about discovering prostate cancer
and it's it is step forward is right at
right from a from bottoms to bottom
feeders muscles more marinara I now
could be history within 85 years because
global warming is making the sea very
acidic and they won't be able to grow so
if you like them start eating them now
and change and change the way the world
operates all the way out and I didn't
realize this that the acidity effects
are obviously whether they can cling on
to the rocks but if there's a twenty
percent drop off rate for mussels
basically twenty percent don't get to
hang on and they just fall on the floor
and die
our twenty percent oppose are getting
eat yeah but an actor either way is it
really when they still die yeah what is
it we're sending muscles down thank you
very much thank you both for your
choices don't forget do send us your
nominations using the hashtag W in our
thank you very much for joining us for a
review of the week we'll be back with
much more next week but for now it's
goodbye from them goodbye and it's
goodbye from me goodbye